how are you holding up what did what has
this been like for you these last few weeks
well for the most part it's just
been a real roller coaster ride
um it's like a never-ending Nightmare and you
know we just try every day me and my family and
my sisters and my brothers we just trying every
day to just take one step each day that's all
One Step each day what do you want people to know
about him okay I mean what the people don't know
about them I mean my brother Legacy is everywhere
right now everybody knows that my brother was an
innocent person my brother everybody knows that
my brother was filled with energy he was like
the light of the room you know he um cared about
people uh he put people before he put himself like
he was very selfless um it was just all around a
great person to be around and you know it sucks
that this happened to him you know like like
some people in this world you just feel like
that should never happen it should never happen
to anybody but at the same time it's like when you
see a person like that and you know a person like
that is just it just takes a toll on you different
because he was really a people person you know he
was a people pleaser and um yeah like the World's
Gonna Miss a person like that yeah I know that
you've been very outspoken and what you believe
should happen to these officers who are charged
with murder what do you think should happen
most definitely I mean I hope they
meet the same fate as my brother
that's just how I feel you know I mean I don't
know what the laws is in Tennessee or whatnot but
for me I believe they deserve the death penalty
what was your reaction when you saw that video
that's the thing I haven't watched it but
I already knew from looking at my brother
I already knew how they treated them because I've
seen it all over the world I've seen it right here
in California all the time police brutality
is nothing new and I already knew as soon as
I seen them photos from him in the hospital I
already knew that they treated my brother like
an animal they beat on him like he was nothing I
don't have to watch the video to see to know that
so yeah you you said on on Facebook you posted
that uh basically saying that you you were sorry
that you weren't there to protect your brother
are you feeling guilty about not being there
always always and I think I speak for
All My Siblings when I say that because
my brother I'm 99 per I'm 99 sure my
brother has never gotten into a fight before
you know and the one time he get
into an altercation with other humans
we wasn't there to protect him you know
as growing up as kids you know having
older brother or older sister and you get into an
altercation your older brother your older sister
will be there to help you and on this night uh
was it January 7th my brother was left alone
because if I was there they would have to kill
me too because I would have fought all of them
my brother was trying to cooperate with
them I would have fought back with him
Ben let me bring you into the conversation because
you know there have been many developments they
seem to come every single day there are
three Memphis fire department personnel who
have been fired uh there are also two other
officers now are on the leave at pending an
administrative hearing what's your response to
that and what questions do you have about it
well done I think as uh Tyrese family and
certainly Jamal have been calling for from
the beginning every last one of them should be
held accountable for this uh this police lynching
of Tyree Nichols I everybody who was on that scene
who contributed in any way should be held fully
accountable and the fact that they relieved the
two offices weeks ago and we're not transparent uh
only brings further questions as to why the
five black officers were fired and charged
and why were the others not charged and so the
family wants full accountability did you see
the original police report and then considering
what the video shows how does that line up Ben
well it is consistent with with Miss robon Tyree
mother said from the beginning when they told them
that they could not go to the hospital because
Tyree had been pepper sprayed and tased and that
he was arrested she said then Don Lemon and you
talked with Miss Ravine and she's a very sincere
person she said she believed that she thought it
was a conspiracy to cover it up from the beginning
Ben I've got to ask you there's a
lot of stuff out there and I just
in in the spirit of accuracy right and
and good journalism did Tyree have any
personal connection to the officers or do
you believe that this was completely random
time the family knows nothing about these rumors
what we do know is that you saw multiple officers
violating his civil rights and we don't
have to speculate about anything because
they were operating under the color of Law
and these police officers know that you cannot
violate people's civil rights Don Lemon and
this is nothing new to this scorpion unit when
you think about the other citizens who said they
were attacked like that so this is a pattern in
practice of police brutality period Point Blank
Jamal before we go I just want to know is there
anything you want people to know about your
brother or what you want to see next from this
um you know I believe everybody knows my
brother now I've seen stuff on my brother
from all across the country even across the world
to be honest and I think people really know that
my brother did not deserve this he was not that
type of person um yeah he's he was just man like
yeah he was just a a good guy around the
board so people know who he is and uh again
I'm gonna say the same thing I've
been saying uh we want Justice we
want everybody that was evolved with
this to you know get that sentence